[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
crazy people
all right
yeah yeah happy thursday everyone it is
thursday i believe
i don't know where i am
so according to a new poll bernie
sanders had the highest favorability
rating among 23 potential 2024
presidential contenders which is kind of
like winning first place at an ugly baby
contest
but here's how bernie celebrated
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah it's amazing he could still move so
quickly but he gets plenty of exercise
running between his many houses
because he had like three houses
you guys didn't know that that's why i
didn't laugh i understand
we'll edit that out
it's true 46 of respondents said they
had at least a somewhat favorable view
towards sanders but 41 said they had an
unfavorable opinion and the rest asked
what's that smell
now i do the math on this but that's
usually for a cat's benefit and she's
still on her honeymoon
i know i think we have tape of that
[Music]
uh
to be young and in hate
so what's this say about politics when
the oldest hairiest most left-wing
person
is the most popular candidate and it's
not hillary
and yes she is harry in one piece she
looks like george the animal steel nice
nice that was for you tyrus nice thank
you bernie even beat out the current
president i think we have footage of him
how can you laugh at that that's
terrible you people are awful
try to report the news and people
so anyway biden's unfavorability rating
was way higher too at 52 percent joe
biden is so unpopular that monkey pox
sent him a thank you note
joe biden is more unpopular than ben and
jerry's new flavor peanut butter and
pork
and even though he's a year older bernie
seems younger than joe maybe because he
doesn't catch a new case of covid every
15 minutes
but to be fair bernie also beat out vice
president kamala harris which isn't
saying much right kamala
that's her responding to news that a nun
was hit by a bus
i know it's disgusting she'd find mass
murder hilarious and then bail out the
murderer
so why is bernie still popular well
first of all the media is soft on him
they don't poke or prod his beliefs so
like any good socialist he expects and
gets a free ride but also it's on us
voters who tend to find economics boring
and sadly it's the boring stuff you know
that kills you
but
what
stop it but i have a theory i call it
the old man theory that's what i call
most of my theories in fact that no
matter how bad someone is it's something
we forget about it once their hair turns
white
which could be the secret to anderson
cooper's career
remember when you were growing up
everyone's grandparents were magical but
they can't be all that great some had to
be jerks right at least 10 of those
adorable silver haired sweethearts were
probably creeps 30 years ago but age
makes people seem more benign it's why
whenever you see an old inmate on death
row you think he can't be that bad he's
got close cropped white hair and
librarian glasses perfect for the parole
board because how could the 78 year old
possibly hurt anyone you could barely
lift a chainsaw now
well it's not about now it's about then
you know in the 80s when this old guy
was in his 30s dismembering hitchhikers
at the back of his jeep wagon here
they really were roomy back then
try finding a hybrid with that kind of
utility space right
sometimes you could fit two three if
they were dwarves but i digress
i'm not saying that bernie sanders is a
serial killer
but i'm not
not saying that bernie sanders is a
serial killer i'm going to let you
decide
but if he is it why would he need to
wear these gloves
just asking a question
but aging softens you with a few of
course notable exceptions
it would take more than age to make her
sympathetic maybe a blood transfusion
and sending her face to the dry cleaner
so maybe it's time to shelf the belief
that with age comes mellowed wisdom
joe biden proved that's not the case he
was a jerk back in the day and he's more
of a jerk now aging had the same effect
on him as the hot sun does on an
uncovered bowl of egg salad
except now the stuff joe says about
millions of americans makes his oldness
seem angrier and meaner as he divides
and separates us like his 1980s comb
over
yeah look at that
you know it is amazing how he was able
to get all of his hair to grow back
since then
how did he do that
but getting older for joe isn't the same
for bernie it's the anger that joe has
about people it's one thing sanders
understands that joe doesn't it's not
the voters who are the problem it's the
policies and the leaders who push them
you shouldn't be raging at people you
serve especially when you're barely
coherent to begin with the problem with
bernie his policies suck harder than
brian stelter trying to drink a
mcdonald's milkshake through a crazy
straw
i know
i know he's gone but i still can't let
go
and if you want to talk russian
collusion look at the man who spent his
honeymoon in the ussr no wonder the
soviets collapsed a year later once a
socialist always a socialist no matter
the age that's because of sunk costs
once you believed in the very worst
ideas for decades it's impossible to let
go no matter how often you've been
proven wrong you already invested the
time so for bernie socialism is like a
baseball card collection that you just
can't throw out
he may look like a kindly grandpa
smelled like one since his hippie days
but bernie's policies don't bring us
hard candy from a dish on the coffee
table they dish out hard times with his
most destructive lefty nonsense yet to
come
welcome
tonight's yes
she's got more mussels than a seafood
paella bosses contributor lara trump
like fonzie he wears a leather jacket
and offers you a reverse mortgage recent
editor large nick gillespie
before she writes a thank you card she
confirms with multiple sources new york
post business reporter lydia moynihan
[Applause]
and mount everest bragged about climbing
him my massive sidekick in the nwa's
world television champion
nick what does this say about i don't
know our political culture and america
in general that bernie leads he's the
oldest guy there
right he's like 112
right if you cut him you have to count
the rings but we're not going to do that
why does it say as a libertarian what
does this say to you uh you know the
only thing i was disappointed in was
that not all of the people had were had
higher unfavorable ratings than
favorable he was one of the few who
didn't yeah and i think that speaks to
the wisdom of the american people that
when we look at the person who's going
to be our next president we mostly think
they suck is that isn't that healthy
i think it is it can become
bad if you can't rally around people but
for the most part i mean it's just
simple realism yeah it drives me crazy
to think that you have to like the
president or that you have to like the
person you're voting for i don't want to
like them i mean i'd rather have like i
would what i want like if i have an
agent or a lawyer walking into a room i
want everybody there to go oh my god i
hate this
that's the president you want you want
somebody to walk in and everybody all
the other countries go
who could i be talking about i have
literally no idea i have no idea either
who am i talking about jimmy carter can
i tell you i think you have a point here
because if i think back to some of my
best teachers i ever had they were tough
a lot of times the kids did not like
them some of my best teachers and
coaches
that taught me the most from whom i
learned the most they were tough and and
they held you to a certain standard and
while you were there maybe you didn't
like them but maybe they had wisdom that
we didn't yet know and understand so i
think you're on to something the thing
is or i'm on something it could be both
it could be both but with this situation
with bernie it really i mean speaks to
sort of how sad and low the democrats
have fallen that this guy who would be
83 if he were elected and inaugurated as
president who is a self-proclaimed
socialist this is the top guy the good
news and maybe scary news is if we
actually got there there would be no
more of anyone's money left to spend uh
like he wants to because joe biden is
actually running everyone dry he's he's
a young 83
yeah so i feel like he's a young lady
he's aspirational he's that yes he's
spry yeah he's spry when somebody
describes you as spry you die in three
months
true it's true lydia how are you i'm
well i'm you know and he doesn't look a
day over 82. no that's true you know
what that is it's a cream rinse
i like that you said that instead of
conditioner yes i don't know what was
your age greg that is so true how did i
say creamy rinse instead of conditioner
that puts me clearly in as a 70s
teenager they used to call it they used
to call it cream rinse
wow lydia why do you think uh sanders is
still popular do you it's because we're
ignorant about uh how economics works in
the land of the blind the one-eyed man
is king i i really come up with that
i am no i have all of the idiomatic free
tell me bertie's blind
that's exactly what i mean
that's exact you got it i was worried it
was gonna go over your head but you got
it a lot of things do go over my head by
the way okay i like your old man theory
and i think young people really like
having an old person as president right
i think gen z obviously makes sense
they're very woke they're into quiet
quitting that's the new phrase you're
not working hard so it makes sense that
they want a politician who's going to
rearrange the tax code to disincentivize
work but i think millennials
millennials don't identify as adults and
we want to abdicate that responsibility
it's why we came up with that phrase
adulting because we
don't think that we should have to do
laundry or taxes and so i think we're
afraid of somebody our own age running
for president but we look at somebody
like bernie sanders and we think okay
well by the time he's 80 surely he must
know something we don't i think it's a
way of us thinking
we don't have to have it together but
maybe he does yeah but they don't
somehow we we thought that wisdom was
stupid tyrus you're looking spry thank
you
i applaud why are you applauding
you know when you sign up in the
audience we have all your information
i can dox you like that
what's that thing called i'll i'll swat
you
how you doing tyrus i'm good i haven't
seen a while yeah it's been a minute
yeah it's been like 10 days 12 days
right yes i think as long as we've been
apart in like seven years i know i know
i missed you
you never called
no i did not no you did not they need to
be a clean break
sometimes
you don't know it until it's gone you
know yes yes
do you have a question no yes um
what are your thoughts
i ain't seen him in 10 days that's what
he came up with no actually actually is
a good question because i i look at this
very positive i'm very excited about
this and this is like
every year the nfl came out and said the
jets are going to win the super bowl
this guy has lost every election that
he's every time he's gone for the
presidency he's lost he's lost horribly
it just goes to show that the moderate
democrats and the independents and
people who used to think that way are
going now we're not even going to look
at we're out there in voting they're not
even looking at the democratic party so
if i was a republican i would be
encouraged by this yeah that bernie
sanders is the you know you figure with
newsom's trip to the white house he
would have some momentum and
i gave kamala bongos it's not working so
i mean there was you tried i tried i
mean i'm trying but
if you're a republican you should be
looking at this going we have a really
good shot to get some things done
because they're looking at the guy who
finishes
low
thirds and seconds uh to be president so
i would be extremely excited about this
if i was a republican yeah it's still
early days though yeah you know it's we
still got two more years right yeah now
it's a lifetime away and when's the last
time a republican presidential candidate
won a majority of the popular vote was
2004. before that it was uh 1990
in 1988. wow way to bring it all down
yeah i think
just keeping it real i have cool
hair it in the numbers now it's the
cream rinse i'm going to say it now so
you can run it back yeah
this election republicans will have the
popular vote i agree with that tyrus
there you go in your face libertarian in
your face
you take your gary johnson's and get out
of here gary johnson he just pulled up
97 percent short
that's true i think he's gonna have that
in the next election or three yeah
we all love gary johnson okay before we
go we got a huge announcement
we're taking the show on the road again
fox nation will be hosting its annual
patriot awards on november 17th at the
at the seminole seminole seminole
seminole thank you it was good hard rock
hotel and casino in hollywood florida
and we're tagging along we'll be there
for three nights of shows november 16th
through the 18th so uh you got to get a
ticket to the patriot awards to be able
to come see us huh they're using us so
go to foxnation.com patriot awards to
get them before they sell out hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else